FABIO YEON: All right.
Let's get started, then.
Welcome.
This is IO-314.
My name is Fabio Yeon.
I'm one of the engineers on the
Global Container Engine Team
and tech lead on a team as well.
"Google Container
Engine and the Path
to Cloud-Native Operations,"
or as I like to call it,
"the pi talk."
Wow, no math person in the room.
[CHUCKLES]
All right, so start
with the basics--
containers.
How many people here have
used or are deploying
containers in production?
Wow, that's a
pretty good number.
How many of you have played
around with containers,
in general?
All right, how many people
have heard about containers?
There, OK.
So let's start with,
then, some simple intro.
What are containers?
The most succinct explanation
I've heard of a container
is that a virtual machine
virtualizes hardware.
A container
virtualizes a kernel.
So what happens, then, is if
you have a bunch of containers
on the same machine, they're
all sharing the same kernel.
But the container runtime
provides enough abstraction
so each one of them
thinks they have
the machine for themselves.
So, why are they useful?
Well, in this little
box called a container,
you can put in just your
application, its dependencies,
and you're done.
Compared to what you
had to do to set up
a deployment on a
VM or a bare metal,
you don't have to install an OS.
You don't have to
configure your networking.
You don't have to configure
and set up the dependencies.
It just shows you, your
application, your binaries,
and a little container
image, and you're done.
In many ways, this is what
I call getting serenity
in a sea of chaos.
All right-- whoops.
Clicker.
So once you start playing
around with containers,
you start running into
little more complicated,
complex scenarios.
And this is where Kubernetes
comes in and helps you out.
Your little box-- if you
have one or two of them,
sure, it's easy to get them
up and running and deployed.
Once you start
getting more of those,
then you start getting
a little bit more help.
Kubernetes helps you
ensure that there's
a place for your
container to run,
makes sure that the proper
number of them are running,
makes sure that the
network packets intended
for your containers gets routed
properly through the cluster
and arrives at the
appropriate place.
And, of course, if
you use Kubernetes,
Google Container
Engine provides to you
the best and purest Kubernetes
experience you can get.
Beyond just allowing to set up
a Kubernetes cluster easily,
Google Container Engine
strives to provide to you
management capabilities
that makes it easy
for you to maintain and
keep your Kubernetes cluster
running.
So the short little
intro, let's dive
in a little bit
into what I'm going
to call cloud-native
management capabilities
and show you some of the things
that we do in Google Container
Engine to help you
be more productive
and to care less about the
machinations of your clusters
and go back to what you
want to do more, which
is maintain your applications
and your services
on Kubernetes.
"Change is the only
constant in life."
I like this quote for
many different reasons.
But that's because in
the little container box,
you have been able to
provide a level of stability
on your thing, on your
applications and your service.
Remember that around
you, the clusters,
things may be
changing continually,
and you have to have
a little strategy
to be able to manage
some of those changes.
So just a quick
overview of the agenda.
Gonna talk a little bit about
Kubernetes, the Kubernetes
versions and why the
version management
is kind of important for you.
Talk a little bit
about node health--
what it takes to
maintain your node health
and how to evaluate that.
There's a little bit about
operations logs and then
talk about some
strategies that we
have come up with for successful
operations of a cluster.
So keeping up with Kubernetes.
So remember, Kubernetes
is an open source project.
As such, it has
its own ecosystem,
it has its own
community, and it also
has its own release cadence.
Kubernetes strives to
get one minor version
release a quarter.
Now [CHUCKLES] this is where
a minor version is like a 1.4,
a 1.5, or sometime
later this month,
I think a 1.6 is
slated to come out.
It seems-- seemingly
like a small thing.
So it's a small number change.
But because Kubernetes is still
a fast-moving, fast-developing
platform, every
quarterly release
tends to be a fairly large
release, a fairly big release.
New features gets launched,
some existing features
get upgraded from alpha to
beta, beta to ga, and so forth.
So every minor
release of Kubernetes
comes in as a big package.
If you look at the
release notes or change
logs for every minor release,
it is very comprehensive.
It is very extensive.
Beyond that, every couple of
weeks patch releases come out.
These may be bug fixes, security
fixes, small improvements
that were missed, and so on.
In Google Container
Engine, our goal
is to provide to you the
latest version of Kubernetes
as quickly as possible.
Order days, if possible,
but if not, sooner.
And we also provide with you
a collection of versions,
because we understand that
not everything is perfect.
And therefore, sometimes you
want to hold back a little bit.
So we provide to you the
latest version of Kubernetes--
one older version,
plus the latest version
of every previous minor
version that's been released.
Now, I know that's a
little hard to parse, which
is why I put an example here.
Currently, the latest version
of Kubernetes available is 1.53,
and that is available.
The previous version
of that is 1.52,
which is the previous
patch release of 1.5.
And then we try to provide
the latest version of the 1.4
branch, which is 1.49, and the
latest version from the 1.3
branch, which is 1.310.
So why does collection
of versions,
why this seemingly subset of
minor versions and not others?
In Kubernetes, the
master and the nodes
can be running
different versions
of Kubernetes binaries.
And the official
support states that--
by the community and so forth,
is that the master and the node
can differ by, at most,
two minor versions.
So Kubernetes Master
is running at 1.5.
The oldest version of Kubernetes
that can be running on a node
and still be
considered supported
is something in the 1.3--
1.4, 1.2, 1.5, 1.3.
When 1.6 comes out,
that will go up to 1.4.
Anything beyond that, meaning
that any version skewed
beyond those two minor releases
is considered out of support
by both Kubernetes and
Google Container Engine.
It goes into what is
called best effort.
Your node may still be
running, it may still work.
But the likelihood is that some
functionality may or may not
work and may break
in the future.
So Container Engine,
remember, will automatically
upgrade your cluster masters.
This is one of the things
that we offer to you
when you create a Kubernetes
cluster on Google Container
Engine.
Among the things that
we do in managing
a master is to upgrade it to
ensure that it is at the latest
version of Kubernetes.
So, as an example, if six months
ago you created a Kubernetes
cluster on Container Engine
at version 1.3, at some point,
your master was upgraded to 1.4.
And if you didn't do anything
[INAUDIBLE] nodes at 1.3,
you were still OK.
It's one version difference.
At some point in
the near past, it
was probably upgraded to 1.5.
So now your master is at 1.5
and your nodes remained at 1.3.
And 1.16 comes out,
and at some point
in the future, when Google
Container Engine upgrades
your masters to 1.6--
uh-oh.
If you have upgraded
or nodes, you're
not officially out of support.
So if [INAUDIBLE] to
do anything, because
of the management of the master
and the auto upgrade that
exists, you have to
upgrade your nodes
at least once every six to
nine months to at least stay
with the support band.
Of course, we highly recommend
that you upgrade more often
to pick up some bug
fixes and security
fixes that may have [INAUDIBLE]
show up in Kubernetes.
So we come now to the
very first feature
that we have on Google
Container Engine
to kind of help you manage
some of this change.
Node auto upgrade.
Just like the cluster master,
where we manage it for you,
node auto upgrade
will monitor the nodes
that you have in the clusters.
And if we detect it, it
is, shall we say, older
than the master, we will
automatically trigger
an upgrade of the nodes.
It is the same exact logic
that is applied if you
upgrade your nodes manually.
It can be enabled and
disabled at any time.
And just briefly, you
can actually do this--
whether the auto upgrade
is enabled or not,
you can always upgrade
your nodes manually first.
If you want to try
out, test out things,
or try to get the latest version
into your cluster sooner.
Now, we kind of try to do this
also in a very good judicious
manner.
Patch upgrades, because they're
typically bug fixes or security
fixes, tend to be applied
much more quickly.
So if my nodes are at
1.50 or 1.51, for example,
and I enable this feature, I
will probably be upgraded to 1.
153 fairly quickly.
Because we understand the minor
version, changes on Kubernetes
can be more disruptive.
And even though Kubernetes
and the community
tries very hard to make sure
that it is not it is not
very disruptive and
lack of compatibility
and all those things
are taken care of--
but because we understand
that sometimes they
can be a little bit
more disruptive,
minor version updates happens
at a slightly slower pace.
So, for example, the
1.4 to 1.5 upgrades
will happen either later cadence
than the minor patch releases.
So how to enable this thing?
You can enable in the gcloud.
When you create a cluster, it
is on the gcloud beta channel
set of commands.
The flag is a enabled
dash auto-upgrade.
You can also do it when
you create a node pool,
and you can also do it in the
UI at cluster creation time.
Like I mention, you can
also enable or disable
disk of ability on node
pool at any given time.
One thing to keep in mind,
if you disable this feature
while an auto
upgrade is running,
it will run to completion.
It just means that next time
you do a scan of your clusters,
it will not auto upgrade it.
Now, let's pick a little
bit behind the scenes
as to what Google Container
Engine is doing for you when
this thing happens and go over
the set of scenarios in case
you want to opt out of
this and do it yourself.
So first thing, as I mentioned
before, you can always
trigger upgrades manually--
does not affect the settings
for auto upgrades.
The first thing is that every
week, Google Container Engine
does a push, and we
do release nodes.
Among the things we publish
in this released node,
along with bug fixes and
teacher announcements,
is what versions of
Kubernetes, if any,
are made available
to you as a user.
We also provide the same
functionality or notification,
both in the CLI, via gcloud
whenever you list it,
or in the UI.
Notice that there
are two versions that
are listed in this
particular output
have two different
types of asterisks.
The more asterisks there are,
typically the worse, the more
dangerous, the worse it is.
In this case, it is telling
you that while my cluster is
one version behind
and the second one is
two versions behind,
I, unfortunately,
did not have one that was
three versions behind.
But you can imagine
that would be--
the mourning would be even
more severe in this one.
And in the UI, of
course, I think
there the upgrade
available notification
is available, as well,
whenever an upgrade is
available for your nodes.
If you want something a
little more programmatic,
gcloud container get
server config will give you
all the current
information about
the potential configurations
of your Google Container Engine
for a particular zone.
And its particular
output, you can
see that the default
cluster version is 1.53,
but the valid masters
are now 1.53 and 1.49,
which is the latest version
from 1.4, which we still
are currently
supporting at this time.
And then your nodes can be
any number of these versions.
Notice that even though 1.27
is still available, it is only
supported if you actually have
your master at the 1.4 branch.
If you have a master in
the one 1.5 of Kubernetes,
the oldest version
of Kubernetes that
could be supported on the
node is in the 1.3 branch.
So thinking a little bit back.
I mentioned that Google
Container Engine managers
your masters.
One of the things that
we do is upgrade them.
You yourself can trigger an
early upgrade of the master
before we get to it, if
you still choose to do it.
And the option is
from the command line.
It's a Container Engine
upgrade, and then you
add the dash, dash
master option.
This tells the system that you
want to upgrade the master.
And then you can go ahead
and trigger a manual upgrade
of your nodes with a send
command, except this time,
you just take out the
dash, dash master.
Why do we upgrade
the master first?
It's because the
node can, at most,
be at the same
version as the master.
You cannot have a node
that is a version higher,
even a patch version.
So in the hypothetical world,
the 1.54 were to come out today
and made available to
Container Engine customers.
If you want to try out 1.54
before we upgrade your cluster,
you would have to upgrade
your masters first to 1.54
and then upgrade your
nodes in your node pools
to 1.54 manually.
And this is
regardless whether you
have enabled auto upgrade
for your nodes or not.
You can just do it yourself.
Ah, so we've started
doing an upgrade
or we trigger an
upgrade of the nodes,
and you detect that
something is going awry,
something has gone wrong,
and you need to stop.
We have two sets of
commands that are currently
in the alpha channel of gcloud.
The first one-- actually,
the second one this list,
but I think the more
important one is you just
want the upgrade to stop.
So you call gcloud, alpha
container operations,
cancel and give you
the operation ID, which
you can get it from listing the
operations currently running.
The operation list
is probably going
to say something
like auto upgrade
or a manual upgrade,
cluster upgrade.
Node upgrade, I think.
You can cancel the operation.
Cancelling an
operation does not stop
an ongoing upgrade of a node.
So if a cluster has five
nodes and you detected that
after the first one,
something has gone south
and you want to stop.
If the second node upgrade
has already started,
the cancelling of
the operation will--
that upgrade will finish,
but the subsequent upgrades
of the nodes in the node
pool will not start.
The upgrade will be
canceled at that point.
Now, your cluster is
going to be in this kind
of a mixed-mode
version between couple
of nodes are in the new
version, a couple of nodes
in the old version.
So then you can do
what's called a rollback.
If you call gcloud alpha
container node pools rollback,
we will then take those nodes
that were at the newer version
and roll them back to
the previous version.
Couple things to keep in mind,
as well, as you're doing this.
This is a recreation of a VM.
So if you happen to have
any local configuration
or local data
stored on those VMs,
fortunately, they don't not
survive an upgrade operation
at this time.
Healthy nodes, healthy clusters.
Keeping your nodes healthy
can be a little tricky.
The nodes can go unhealthy
for a number of reasons.
You can run out of resources.
Maybe you over provisioned
stuff and you used
too much memory, too much CPU.
It can run on a local disk.
Maybe you have a configuration
problem or a bug in Kubelet
that is causing it to crash.
Maybe your workload is
triggering a kernel bug,
or, of course, network
segmentation network drivers
crash, so on and on.
Some of these are auto
recoverable by Kubernetes,
specifically the first
two, where you run out
of memory or resource.
Some signals provided
to Kubernetes
to the cluster master and
the rescheduler controller
on the master, you're
supposed to observe
these things happening and say,
oh, this node is overloaded.
Let me just take away
some pods from it
and scatter them elsewhere.
So they're self-healing
for the most part.
As long as you have enough
resources in your clusters,
then there's nothing
you need to do.
But if your click Kubelet
starts crashing on you,
if your current node
became deadlocked
because you happened to trigger
a kernel bug, what then, then?
This is where it starts getting
a little more interesting.
Second thing to remember
about node health
is that it is the master's
evaluation of your node's
health that is important.
Why?
Because it is the cluster
master that determine what pods
are scheduled where.
So if your master thinks that
your node is unhealthy or vice
versa, you may not
schedule anything on it
if it's considered-- if
it thinks it's unhealthy,
or if it's giving a false signal
that is healthy but it is not,
and we try to schedule work
into an unhealthy node.
So that's something
to keep in mind.
It's kind of important, is
that the self-evaluation
of the health of the node
is less important here.
It is what the master
thinks of your node's health
at that time that is important.
And, of course,
repairs like upgrades
are typically limited to
recreations of a node.
Oops, wrong button.
So this comes to a second
[INAUDIBLE] container
on Google Container Engine to
help you manage your cluster.
It is node auto-repair.
It is the semantic equivalent
of the master repair
that we already do for
your cluster today.
But this-- this is where we
are observing and monitoring
your nodes.
We are taking into
account the master's view
of your node health state.
We are also evaluating
other signals around it.
We take a look at the signals
from the managed instance
group backing your node pool.
We also sometimes take
a look at the signals
provided by the node itself.
With those signals, the of it
all, be coming to an evaluation
whether your node
is healthy or not.
Too many unhealthy signals
will trigger repair--
in this case, a
recreation of the node, in
attempt to get it
back into a good state
and having rejoined the cluster.
We also try to make sure that
we rate limit this so that we're
not doing this too often.
Now, why rate limit?
It's because sometimes
the node going on health
and may be triggered
by your workload.
And if you start triggering
this wait too often,
we may be in a situation
where the node never
is alive long enough
to do any useful work.
So we have somebody do some
of the rate limiting as well.
Currently in beta--
as a matter of fact,
I think it's rolling
out as we speak,
and so fairly soon you
should be able to have
this capability show up in
the UI and in the CLI as well.
How do I enable it?
Just like auto-repair,
the flag is
dash dash enable auto-repair.
You can do this at
cluster creation
time, at node for creation time.
And, as a matter of
fact, I would highly
recommend that you
enable both of them--
auto-repair and auto-repair, to
make your life a little easier
when you run Kubernetes on
a Google Container Engine.
One more thing before I
go into the next slide,
which I've [INAUDIBLE] here.
You can also enable and
disable this at any given time.
It is just like
for auto upgrades.
You do a gcloud beta
container node pools update,
and you can enable or disable
auto-repair on your cluster--
on your-- sorry--
on your node pool
at anytime you that you want.
So let's now peek
into behind the scenes
and see a little bit of
what Google Container
Engine is doing on your behalf.
And kind of give you an idea if
you wanted to do this yourself,
what kind of things
you have to do.
So I mentioned that it
is the master's view
of your node health
that matters.
So how does a master know
what's going on in a node?
The Kubelet publishes to
the master periodically
a bunch of information.
And one of them
is its evaluation
of its node health plus what's
going on in its internals.
All this information is
available from the node object
from your Kubernetes master.
So from the command
line, you yourself
can get the same data by calling
[INAUDIBLE] control, get nodes.
Of course, in this
output, it gives
a little more
formatted-shortened version
of it.
But if you see the
JSAR or YAML output,
you can actually
get at the raw data.
And in a little
bit, in the demo,
kind of show you how
I can look for this.
So you're listening your
nodes, and you're determined
and one of them has gone
unhealthy, not ready.
So what are the
steps now for you
to try to get back
to a good state?
Well, the first thing you should
do is cordon off your nodes.
What this thing does
is tell the scheduler,
hey, regardless of what's going
on in this particular node,
don't schedule any
further work on it.
Next thing we do, we
attempt to do a drain,
try to do a graceful
drain of all the pods,
make sure they all
go away some place
so that the pod becomes empty.
This may or may not
succeed depending
upon the state of Kubelet and
other things on your node.
If your node had a hard deadlock
because of a kernel issue,
this may not work.
But at least we try.
The next thing is we try to list
your manage instance group back
in your node pool.
And from that manage
instance group,
we have to identify the
specific node from that
and then try to tell the manage
instance group, hey, please
recreate that node.
Because we have set up--
on Google Container Engine
we have set up your cluster
using instance group
templates, a simple recreation
of it using the
existing template
gets your back a node
into your cluster.
Operations log--
[CHUCKLING] as we
start getting more and
more capabilities on Google
Container Engine to help
you manage your cluster more
easily, a question that keeps
coming up is, like, hey,
how do I find out when you
guys have done something
on my cluster?
So the first that we
have done right now
is that we are augmenting the
operations log for a Container
Engine to contain more
information about when
we do automated operations on
your clusters on your behalf.
So before we had repair clusters
and upgrade masters available,
and we're adding auto-repair
nodes and auto-upgrade nodes
as additional
operation log types
so that you can find out
whenever we have done
these things on your behalf.
How do you get to
the operational log?
Well, gcloud container
operations list
will give you a order list
of all the operations that
have been done on your cluster.
Actually, I think
it's beyond just
your cluster-- is in your
project across your clusters.
And then if you do a
container operations describe
on an operation, it gives
a little more detail
as to what we did and
what the status was.
Were we successful?
Did we fail?
So on and on.
Node pools and
resource management--
another favorite topic of mine.
How many people here have
heard about node pools
or have used node pools?
Handful.
OK, good.
So what are node pulls?
Node pulls-- the shortest
definition is just a collection
of nodes managed together.
From a Google Container
Engine perspective,
what it means is that you
can have multiple node
pools in your cluster,
each are defining
a particular configuration.
And When I say configuration,
I mean machine type,
machine resources, and
Kubernetes versions,
scopes, and on and on.
Within a node pool,
all the machines
have to have the same
exact configuration.
They have to be the
same exact machine type,
they have to have the
same exact machine--
Kubernetes version.
They must have the same
exact machine resources.
So if I ask for an
n1-standard-4, with, let's say,
two local SSDs, every single
machine in that node pool
will have the same
configuration.
But, of course, I can have
multiple of these in a cluster,
so this gives me
an additional level
of functionality--
flexibility, as well, where
I can have different machine
types and different--
and mix and match these
to meet my workload
and my resource
needs more carefully.
And this is also a foundational
unit for many management stuff
that I talked about, so
when, before, I was talking
about cluster
creation, enabling it
at cluster creation
or node pool creation,
when you create a cluster on
Google Container Engine, what
is actually happening
is that we're
creating the master
and so forth,
and we are also
creating a default node
pool for your cluster.
So all the options available
for creating a node pool
are available on your
cluster creation as well.
So let's take a
look and some things
that you can do with node pools
might be kind of interesting.
So can we switch to the
demo machine, please?
Ah, OK.
So you go container
clusters list.
And here I have my cluster
that I created for this demo.
It is currently running on
master 1.53, and oh, wow--
my master was upgraded
since I ran this demo,
so my nodes, right
now, are version 1.52.
So now I have a notification
that a node is--
upgrade is available.
It also tells me that my
current cluster is running
and, of course, my
master IP address.
Let's take a peek
underneath, then,
at my node pools for
this particular cluster.
Of course, pedantically--
has to be plural.
I have three node pools
configured for this cluster.
I have a main focus
comprised of [INAUDIBLE].
I have something that I call
a pre-pool of n1-standard-2s,
and something that I called
a lowmeme pool, which
is running the custom machine.
A custom 2x2048,
which signals to me
that this is a two-core machine
with only two gigs of RAM.
Let's then describe
the main pool--
oops, let me pipe that.
OK.
n1 [INAUDIBLE] 4,
identification scope's defined.
The number of initial
counts enabled.
And, of course,
in our management,
I can see that I have enabled
both auto repair and auto
upgrade for this
particular pool.
OK, I think--
interesting on this one.
But if I go to my pre-pool,
among the things that you'll
notice on this
particular listing
is that this thing is
comprised of preemptible VMs.
Preemptible VMs, of course,
are options provided to you
from DCP, where the costs
for these are lower.
But in return, the VM may be
preempted underneath of you
with a moment's notice.
But if you have a workload that
are preemptible-friendly or can
be preemptible easily,
this is an easy way for you
to instantiate a couple node
pools in your cluster to have
this and leverage it--
the lower of cost
that they provide.
And then, of course, the final
one, which is my lowmeme pool.
It is just like my main pool,
except the difference here
is that I'm running
custom 2x2048 machines.
So, like I said,
very low memory,
high, superior kind of
workloads would benefit
from this kind of node pool.
So previously, I have already
pre-deployed a number of pods
on this particular cluster.
So let's take a
look at all of them,
make sure they're all running.
So I have deployments
that are very high CPU.
Some deployments that are
just regular, main workloads.
And I have something
that I'm calling
preemptible workloads
are workloads
that are eminently preemptible.
With a little bit of trickery--
and this is where I will
cut and paste the command,
because I can never
remember from memory.
I called [INAUDIBLE]
control pause
provided a JsonPath
path that says,
hey, fish out this little fields
from your particular listing
and then combine them
to write this output.
So in this view, you can see
that all my pods are listed
there like before, but
now I'm also listing
which node they are running on.
And you can see this thing
scattered all over the place.
My high-CPU workload's
running in a variety
different machines.
My main machines-- I have
main workloads running
on a variety of other machines.
But more importantly--
they've been not a good idea--
I have some workloads that are
running on my preemptible VMs.
Should be OK, maybe,
but certainly not ideal.
Because maybe
they're not workloads
that you want to run
on a preemptible VM.
So, how do we then
take care of that?
Let's take a look,
then, in a node
and see what I can find out.
So if I list the raw
Json object for a node,
you will notice a couple of
things here among the metadata
so far.
It is that there's a
whole section for labels.
Some of these labels
are applied on each node
by the Kubernetes runtime,
and they are identified easily
by the kubernetes.io prefix.
So thing like machine
architecture, in the 64,
machine OS--
Linux.
Down here-- host name,
host name on machine.
You'll also notice
a few of these
that are actually set by
Google Container Engine itself.
They are prefixed
with cloud.google.com.
In this case by default,
every single node
that we create on
Google Container Engine
has, automatically,
as part of it,
the node pool name
associated with it.
And, of course, the other thing
there is this other label.
On Google Container Engine,
when you create a node pool,
you are allowed to provide
to it a comma-delimited list
of key value pairs that become
part of your node labels.
So you can, then, use these on
your pods spec in Kubernetes
so that it ensure that
those workloads, those pods,
ends up at a node that
has this label in them.
One more thing I want
to show up along here.
This is another node.
In this case, this happens to be
a VM that is a preemptible VM.
When you create a
preemptible VM--
a node pool, sorry-- in
Google Container Engine,
we will automatically add
apply this label as well,
so you don't have to do it.
You can certainly add more,
like I had done below,
where I've added the pre label
as well, where you can actually
add the Google Cloud Comp.
You can use this label as part
of a node selector on your pod
spec as well.
Oh, before I go off--
I mentioned earlier
about node condition.
If you want to explore
a little bit more
about doing the node
health evaluation yourself,
every single node contains
this array of node conditions
under the conditions list.
And there are a
variety of these.
Some of them talk
about [INAUDIBLE]
health, disc, memory, pressure.
And, of course, the bottom one
is whether the Kubelet is ready
or not.
This is part of the signal
that is pushed from the node
to the masters periodically
to let the master know
what the status of the node is.
And this is the signal that both
the master and Google Container
Engine uses--
well, one of the signals--
to determine whether the
node is healthy or not.
So back to this demo.
I have, then, deployment YAML
for my high-CPU workload.
Of course, I have commented,
for demo purposes,
the node selector.
So let's go ahead and
delete the comment tags
and make sure that the
node selector's there.
I'm gonna go to my
other workloads as well.
And remove the node
selector comments.
And notice that on this one, at
least, while on the other ones
I've used my custom labels that
I've set up on each node pool,
on this one, I
just decided to use
the one that Google
Container Engine sets
for preemptible VMs.
Might be kind of nice,
because at this point,
I'm not relying upon a
custom label that I've set
or the pool name or
anything like that.
I'm just using an automatically
set label that Google Container
Engine has put on it.
So it's available across
any VM that is printable.
Let me go ahead and replace
the deployment on Kubernetes.
And preempt.
OK?
Give control, get pods.
Bunch terminating,
bunch running,
bunch container running.
We'll let this run
for a little bit,
let everything kind
of settled down again.
Mhm.
Wow, taking a little bit longer.
OK, things seem to be
settling in, settling down.
Things are getting scheduled.
Excellent.
Ah, everything is running again.
So if we go back to that
somewhat complicated Kubelet
control that I had before,
what you'll find here now
is all of my high
CPU deployment--
it is now running on
my low-memory pool.
My main workload
is my main pool.
But more importantly than
anything else, my preemptible,
friendly workload
is now all scheduled
and running on preemptible VMs.
So with this, I was
able to, shall we say,
make sure that my high-CPU
workloads end up on machines
that have very high CPU
of low amounts of memory--
save me some money,
ensured that the proper VMs
are assigned for those.
My main workload
can be whatever.
My generic set of workloads
can go on the main workload.
But more importantly,
my preemptible
workloads that low priority,
low cost are all set up
and now are all running
on my preemptible VMs,
exactly as I desired to be.
Couple more things
to keep in mind--
there are more node
selector options
becoming available to you as
part of the Kubernetes 1.6
release.
So, for example, node
selector right now is a match.
One of the things
that is coming up
that might be kind of
interesting, especially
in this kind of scenario,
is the [INAUDIBLE].
You may have workloads
that I don't really
care where they run,
I just don't want them
to run on this type of VM--
preemptive VM, for example.
So that's one of the options
that will come online--
available in the
1.6 timeframe, I
believe, where you can just
state that in your pod spec
and will be available
when you deploy them.
So can you go back to
the slides, please?
All right.
So a couple of slides I put it
in here for you to reference.
Feel free to take a look at it,
how to list some node pools,
how to create the node pools
that I've-- whoops, sorry--
that I've used for this demo.
Notice the machine
types, notice the dash,
dash printable option as an
option, and the node labels,
how to specify these
on your node pools.
And, of course, in assigning
pods to node pulls,
it's the node selector
option in your YAML file.
OK, some final notes.
Upgrades can be disruptive.
So to help mitigate
them, you can use--
the upgrades are for node pool.
So you kind of use
them to segment
the upgrades of your cluster
so that you can have either
a canary test kind of pool,
you can try out newer versions.
So you have an existing workflow
that is running at version 1.51
and you want to
try a 1.53, you can
spin up another
node pool at 1.53,
schedule some workload on
that particular node pool,
make sure everything
works fine before you
let the rest of your
cluster be upgraded.
Consider having what I
call the one-node slack
to ensure proper capacity.
When we do upgrades, we take
down one node, do the upgrade,
bring it back up.
Go on to the next
node, and so on.
While the one node is
down and being upgraded,
it would be nice for you to have
enough slack on your cluster
so that whatever pod was running
there can find a new home
while the upgrade is occurring.
Google Container
Engine limits you
to having one cluster operation
running at any given time.
Now just to differentiate
between the Container Engine
operation versus the Kubernetes
operation, for example,
these are things like adding
or deleting a node pool,
updating a cluster-wide
configuration,
doing an upgrade, a
repair, any kind of events.
All those are serial on
Google Container Engine
for various logistic reasons.
So for the most part,
this restriction
is not a big deal
except if you're
upgrading a fairly large
cluster or node pool.
And you can imagine
that because we're
doing the upgrade
sequentially, it
may take a little while
for it to complete.
In the middle of it, if
you have to do something
on your cluster, go ahead
and cancel the upgrade.
It will stop at a good point.
You can do whatever
operation you
have to do on your
clusters, and then
re-issue the upgrade command.
It will just kind of pick
up from where it was left,
scanning your nodes
there we have,
skipping those that have
already been upgraded and just
keep on going the rest of them.
And, of course,
we're truly trying
to make progress and try to
minimize some disruptions.
And we have more
capabilities that we're
going to be adding in a future
for upgrades and repairs.
Some of the best practices
that we have found--
pod disruptions are a reality.
Try to prepare your
workload for them.
There are a number
of capabilities
being added to Kubernetes that
are gonna help you with that.
So please do take
advantage of them.
And we'll keep integrating them
into Google Container Engine.
Do use deployments of
replica sets for your pods.
Make sure that you have
enough sufficient redundancy.
The second point is
actually kind of important.
In the cloud-native
world, please
to not write set once and
forget configuration scripts.
The mindset you need
to have is reconciler.
You need to write reconcilers
that read the current state.
If it's not the desired
state that you want,
do some action to
try to get there.
And then once it's completed,
go to sleep and then
start over from step 1 again.
This way, whether it's a
repair event, an upgrade event,
or some other things
that happening outside
of the container, if you
have some configuration
that you absolutely
need, you know
that at some point, if it goes
out of alignment for whatever
reason, it is a temporary
thing that hopefully
should autocorrect itself.
And, of course,
please use node pools.
Organize your resource more
efficiently in your cluster.
Allow you to have
[INAUDIBLE] configurations.
Leverage different types of
machines, different types
of resources, and so on.
A quick recap--
change is constant.
Please be prepared.
Do enable auto-upgrade,
and then try auto-repair.
Operations logs--
please look into them
to see if-- whenever
we do something,
we'll try to make sure that they
all end up in your operations
log for your clusters
so nothing is hidden.
Use your node pools to
organize your resources.
And, of course, think
reconciler, not set and forget.
For those that may
not be familiar,
here are a couple links for
the Container Engine website,
the Google Groups where
the release notes come out
whenever we do a push
on Container Engine.
A lot of members of
our engineering team
are on Stack Overflow, so
if you have a question that
is container-engine
specific, please use
the tag, the Google Container
Engine tag in Stack Overflow.
And, of course, as
always, the Kubernetes
GitHub depositary of highly
technical, kind of complicated.
But always looking for
contributors for the Kubernetes
project.
And while you're
here at GCP Next,
I highly recommend going
to other container talks
if you want to find
out more about us.
IO205, I think is this
afternoon and it's
a good intro to other
capabilities and features
that are being added to
Google Container Engine.
And, of course, I also
want to highlight IO307,
even though the
title says ABC is a--
Google Container Engine
tips and best practices
is actually a talk mostly about
monitoring with your Google
Container Engine cluster.
And with that, I want to
say thank you for coming.